welcome to the live stream Wow so much
to talk about glad you're with me today
I I don't even know where to start I
mean it's gotten to the point where
every day is scandal after scandal every
day is another embarrassment
another spilling the beans of
information that our president should
not really be talking to other people
about if you watched or listened to
today's program and the clips are
starting to come out now the first one
about two hours ago the second one a
half hour ago the clips from today's
program
III don't know whether to just start at
the top or sort of how how to even deal
with this it's it's insane what's going
on I guess the first thing is let's just
talk about the live stream if this is
your first live stream yes this is
really live unless you're watching a
replay it is 6:30 1 p.m. on May 24th
2017 it is really live I'm here talking
to you right now
unless this is a replay number 2 super
chat is on you can use super chat which
is the dollar sign below the chat window
and I will take questions and comments
through super chat during the entire
stream number 3 new members and patrons
who sign up or pledge during the stream
will get a live shout out and thank you
from me I will sing your praises of
course membership is at david pakman.com
slash membership there's a coupon code
which will save you 40% use it if you
like it's I voted 17 all one word all
lowercase you can also make a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show more
on that later obvious trolling and hate
will get you banned either by the
moderators or me if I notice it if
you're trolling is subtle then it
probably won't get you banned because no
one will notice
as far as patreon goes we're up to
fifteen hundred and thirty-eight patrons
the goal for this live stream is sixteen
hundred if we get to sixteen hundred
patrons which means just 62 more doesn't
matter the amount a dollar a month
counts if we get to sixteen
patrons by the end of this stream I will
create and release exclusively to you as
a viewer of this stream a coupon code
which will give you 50% off of
membership okay so that's patreon.com
slash david pakman show 1600 is the
number that we are looking for okay so
let's just let's just jump in so on
today's program I mean it was just story
after story each story that has been at
the top of our show in the first segment
the two or three stories at the
beginning of the show for the last
couple of weeks under normal
circumstances each of those stories
would warrant 24-hour news coverage for
three to five days but in the in the era
of Trump they don't because it's scandal
after scandal Donald Trump has lawyered
up okay with regard to the Trump Russia
scandal Donald Trump now has personally
lawyered up and that is in and of itself
significant because that means that
there is at least the anticipation of a
possibility that Donald Trump will need
to personally defend himself above and
beyond the White House Council which is
sort of like the White House staff
attorneys in some way but it's also
interesting because when it comes to
Trump there's always some either double
standard or Russia connection with
everything he does Trump's lawyer
defending him with the entire
representing him I guess right now would
be the right way to say it within the
Russia scandal is a guy who also is the
lead attorney in a federal civil lawsuit
against a majority Russian government
own bank called Sberbank not Burbank but
super bank you can't write this stuff
you truly cannot write this stuff and
that that in and of itself the fact that
the president now has a personal
attorney representing him when it comes
to the possible collusion with a non
friendly foreign state to gain the White
House that would be a major story we've
had three or four other scandals related
to Trump over the last 48 hours barely
even computes okay number two from
today's program John Brennan former CIA
director he showed up yesterday and
justified before the House Intelligence
panel now I know you're probably if
you're like me and many of you are I
don't even know what that means just
sounds funny if you're like me you may
not have that much confidence in the
house investigation into Trump Russia at
this point but nevertheless because of
the entire Devin Nunez scandal
nevertheless former CIA director John
Brennan shows up and says yeah I was I
was very concerned when I was still at
the CIA about the contacts that were
going on between Trump people and and
Russian individuals and Republicans they
play this semantic game where Brennan's
not the current CIA director right so he
can't really say with certitude yes or
no whether there was or wasn't collusion
right between Trump and Russia so
Republicans asked Brennan can you tell
us though director Brennan whether there
was collusion between Trump and Russia
is there any evidence whatsoever and
John Brennan says I don't know I'm not
part of the investigation I'm not part
of the CIA anymore the FBI is doing the
investigation I can't say and then the
Republicans say so what you're saying
director Brennan is that if after this
hearing Democrats try to say that you
pointed to Russian collusion they would
be misrepresenting what you're saying
right they would be wrong you've not
pointed to any collusion Brennan's as
well
I I can't say one way or the other I'm
not involved in the investigation ah so
it's not true if Democrats say that
there is evidence of collusion it's not
true now that it's not true it's that
I'm not involved I don't know I'm not
involved in the investigation just
embarrassing embarrassing the way that
Republicans have been handling that and
then we really got into I mean the most
cringe-worthy moment for me from trumps
entire trip so far is this note that he
wrote at Yad Vashem in Jerusalem the
Holocaust Memorial and we put up the
notes and you can google all this stuff
it's all widely available we put up the
note that President Barack Obama left
when he visited the Holocaust Memorial
somber note
about a page Barack Obama asked in every
way we put up the note that george w
bush left george w bush not known as a
particularly eloquent speaker but he
understood the gravity of the entire
thing and left the note in the guestbook
at yad vashem saying something along the
lines of god bless israel right
god bless israel George W Bush and
Donald Trump left a note in all caps
like a little kid I mean it's just
bizarre that the optics of it are
bizarre it is a great honor to be here
with all my friends
so amazing and we'll never forget it
exclamation points is everything you
leave like at a Bar Mitzvah right it's
the sort of thing you would put when
you're 12 and you go to a Bar Mitzvah or
a bat mitzvah if it's 12 more likely and
had a great time great seeing all my
friends never will forget it exclamation
point all caps print right but that's
what Donald Trump wrote at the at the
Holocaust Memorial in Jerusalem one of
the most somber and solemn places I mean
it's just absolutely amazing and
tomorrow on the show there's actually
video this is just it's it's
unbelievable I mentioned today on the
show that when Trump arrived in Israel
from Saudi Arabia he said we we've
arrived from the Middle East of course
Israel is in the Middle East and there's
actually now video of this and there's a
guy I forget exactly who it was let me
see if I have it in my notes here it was
I want to make sure I have this that
during the video you see Israeli
ambassador Ron Dermer face palms when
Trump arrives in Israel and says we've
arrived we've been in the Middle East up
until this point I mean it's you know
what's going on I think at this point
you have a sense of what's going on
let's get to some of the super chats ok
$2 super chat from Le no comment or
question thank you very much $20 super
chat from Frank macwrite watched your
show the other day I understand how
removing Trump isn't exactly a win for
the opposition however my issue is that
we're wasting years of getting real
things done which also seems unavoidable
at this point ok so Frank is referencing
my story where I pointed out that
might not be the best thing to for
Democrats and or progressives to impeach
Donald Trump it wasn't me saying I don't
think Trump should or shouldn't be
impeached obviously if the evidence is
that Trump should be impeached Trump
should be impeached but what I pointed
out was that it would be a disaster if
Democrats lead the impeachment and then
it fails to remove Trump because
remember the impeachment is just the
start of the process if Democrats lead
an impeachment with a couple Republicans
and it does not ultimately lead to
Trump's removal Trump is energized Trump
is completely energized and empowered
and it's a disaster for Democrats and
progressives if Republicans lead the
impeachment for the good of the party so
to speak and it succeeds that's actually
not that good for Democrats either
because some Republican voters will be
mad about it trumpets that committed
trumpets but some Democrats some
Republicans rather will say hey you know
what Trump was Trump did bad things but
my party did the right thing and
Republicans could still do well in 2018
and 2020 the other possibility is that
we have to think about is obviously if
Pence gets in there you're talking Frank
about we're wasting time getting real
things done if Mike Pence becomes
President of the United States it will
become boring instantly right it's not
day-to-day scandals and facepalm and
cringe but he's a hardcore right-wing
ideologue who could actually get things
done and they won't be things that we
want done okay so I think that it's just
important not to see this impeachment
scenario as some kind of panacea because
it it may not be that it may not end up
being that gr cent the $5 super chat
saying pack D Z take it from the top
bring us to the progressive pastures of
green emerald utopia science fiction is
to us a trump las' world love gr all
right thanks very much gr appreciate
appreciate the message Chris utt Singh
sent a $5 super chat Michael Shermer was
on serious inquiries only and identity
politics came up would you be interested
in going on serious inquiries
and having a discussion with Thomas I
don't know who Thomas is or what serious
inquiries only is I interviewed Michael
Shermer last week I would be glad to
consider going on you know if it's
something that is not going to expose me
to a new audience of any significant
magnitude it may not be the best use of
my time but I'm more than willing to
consider going on I'll make a note to
check out what that is and if they want
to contact me I will be glad to consider
it Viktor Savelle has sent the $20 super
chat saying thank you David for the
fantastic job if Trump is impeached and
pence takes the role of president what
are your thoughts on the possibility of
Pence's removal from the position as
well as its and its consequences okay so
I addressed a little bit of this in some
way but you're getting at something else
which is it's possible it's possible
that if it depends on we're thinking
ahead many steps here depending on why
Donald Trump could be hypothetically
impeached and removed from office if it
is campaign coordination with Russia
there's two possibilities which could
lead to Mike Pence not ultimately being
the president and we're thinking way
ahead here okay but Viktor you asked the
question so I'm going to answer it if
it's determined that pence was just as
complicit as Trump in the collusion with
Russia you could make the case that why
are we going to put Mike Pence in there
he could be removed for the exact same
thing that's number one number two if
it's determined in some definitive way
and I'm thinking way ahead at this point
this would be incredibly difficult to do
but if it's determined that Donald Trump
is only the president due to activity
that was illegal or falls under you know
treason misdemeanor high crimes and
misdemeanors whatever whatever phrase
you want to use rather than an
impeachment there could be a case made
for an annulment of the election this
would be effectively unprecedented in
American history what we've seen with
Trump is already unprecedented in
American in American history so who
knows if that would happen but if we if
you want to make the case of for an
annulment
the entire election would be annulled
what do you do then I have no idea what
are the legal repercussions I have
absolutely no idea but but that those
would be two scenarios in which Mike
Pence would not ultimately be President
of the United States Felipe Garcia sent
a five-dollar super charge what do you
think of running on impeaching Trump in
2018 if we elect the Democratic House of
Representatives president Pelosi I don't
know if running on impeachment is a good
idea and again this is because I think
that if it's Democrats leading
impeachment bearing in mind that
impeachment is not the removal of the
president it is the start of a process
to explore whether the president did
something worthy of removal if Democrats
lead an impeachment and it fails that is
a huge matzo ball hanging out there
right it is a major problem politically
for Democrats and it empowers Trump I
would say so I think that running on the
impeachment of Trump is a major risk and
I don't know that that's a I don't know
that that's a direction I would go okay
so all right I've gotten caught up on
super chats we talked about Trump and
his bizarre note that he left at the
Holocaust Memorial in Israel we talked
on the program today about that leaked
phone call between Donald Trump and the
Filipino president Rodrigo Duterte and
in that I won't rehash the entire
analysis but in this transcript that has
been leaked which again people hear me
talk about this they say oh but David
that's fake news it's not real nobody's
agreeing that that's what took place
blah blah blah no nobody is denying that
that this is this is the transcript that
was leaked that this was the transcript
that was leaked was real Donald Trump
criticized President Obama - Rodrigo
Duterte
again still with the insecurity talking
about Obama you're the president now
conduct business with the President of
the Philippines don't don't slam Obama
but also and this now is becoming a
bigger and bigger story Donald Trump
revealed the presence of two American
nuclear submarines in Korean waters when
talking to President Rodrigo de
about kim jeong-hoon and we've now
learned that the pentagon was shocked by
the fact that Donald Trump would reveal
that over the phone in that way the this
so this is now the second time in a
couple of weeks of course last week I've
lost track of time last week or the week
before you had Donald Trump in the Oval
Office with two Russian agents two
Russian officials one of whom the
Russian ambassador to the u.s. Sergei
kiss' lyac is a suspected recruiter of
Russian spies Donald Trump leaked
information about a suspected Isis plot
we now know that that information came
from our ally Israel whatever you think
about Israel's politics
internal-external whatever we get
valuable intelligence information from
Israel and Israel now is going to modify
exactly as I said could happen the way
in which they share information with the
United States
okay so already Trump's loose lips
creating problems with our allies now
Trump gets on the phone with Rodrigo
Duterte
and says hey we've got firepower I don't
want to use it but we've got firepower
that 20 times stronger than what Kim
jong-un has and we've got two nuclear
subs there in Korean waters Pentagon
didn't want that said Pentagon did not
authorize the Filipino president to be
told that that's what's going on who by
the way at the time that he took Trump's
phone call was in some kind of group
meeting with other leaders and three
defense officials from the Pentagon have
now said we never talk about submarines
we don't talk about the location of our
submarines and Donald Trump gets on the
phone and says hey Kim jong-un he's a
madman
we've got two nuclear subs in Korean
waters this is a national security risk
Donald Trump ran as though he was going
to be some kind of reversal from Obama
who according to the trumpet was not
keeping us safe although look at what
happened under george w bush look at
what happened under Barack Obama tell me
tell me what evidence what data you can
point to that suggests Obama was not
keeping us safe and Trump said Obama was
not keeping us safe but I'm go
keep us safe how does endangering an
Israeli asset in the Middle East who
clearly has made inroads with Isis how
does that keep us safe how does it keep
our allies safe how does telling Rodrigo
Duterte during a casual phone call the
location of two American nuclear
submarines how does that keep us safe I
explained to me how we are safer because
of the great national security leader
Donald Trump as a result of the things
that he is saying it makes absolutely no
sense to me whatsoever let me send out a
couple of thank-yous here we do have a
membership membership is the number one
funding source for our program you can
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership on the second page of the
sign up you will notice the coupon code
field pointed out by that big red arrow
the coupon code that you can use to save
40% off of membership you get a hundred
percent of the benefits but you only pay
60% of the cost is I voted 17 and I want
to send major major thank yous to
Frances Ellen Greer jr. who just signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
I want to send a major thank you to
felissa
Lazar who signed up while we've been
chatting here at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you it's because of
people like Francis and felissa that
we're able to do what we do thank you to
heidi scott who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using I
might add the coupon code
I voted 17 thanks to Christopher
Teixeira who has signed up also using
the coupon code for 40% off at david
pakman.com slash membership and thank
you to Sherry flack who has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership Sheree
choosing to use choosing to use the
coupon code
I voted 17 which saves you 40% you don't
have to use it it's available if you
want to use it and then of course
pledges of any amount even a dollar a
month welcome at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we started the stream
with 1538 patrons and I hope that by the
end of the stream that number will be
higher if we get to 1600 patrons during
the stream I will create and announce to
you a coupon code for 50% 50% discount
off of membership so that that if we hit
1600 patrons during the stream okay
the david pakman show has been getting
some some nice press lately some nice
articles written about different aspects
of what's going on with the show I want
to tell you about a couple of these
articles okay first and foremost both
articles relate to the YouTube
advertiser boycott alright if you have
no idea what this is I'm going to give
you the 30-second summary this as the
story has gotten longer and longer I've
condensed the summary more and more to
not spend a lot of time on what it is
YouTube advertiser boycott March 31st
YouTube flips a switch new algorithm
decides when ads play before videos on
YouTube that's how channels like ours
make money because of that the day they
flip this algorithm on we lost 99% of
our revenue 99% of our revenue overnight
gone because of this new algorithm and
because some of our content was quote
controversial unquote since then some of
that revenue has recovered and currently
we're earning about a third of what we
were on YouTube prior to this crisis so
that's why we've been pushing membership
in patreon I mean it's just it's numbers
right it's math we've got to make up
that money and that's why we we've been
talking about patreon and membership so
much so mid-april really good article in
The New York Times April 17th by Amanda
Hess was written the article is called
how YouTube's shifting algorithms hurt
independent media very well-researched
article very thorough article and you
can find it by googling how YouTube's
shifting algorithms hurt independent
media and it really featured the David
Pakman show it was an article about the
new YouTube advertiser boy
and it basically exclusively featured
the david pakman show and it was an
extraordinary article it was actual
investigative journalism Amanda Hess
actually did the right thing talked to
me went back and tried to verify
independently the allegations that I
made came back to me asked me for
supporting evidence as to how we were
being affected by the YouTube ad boycott
really really good article more recently
however earlier late last week an
article in Wired was published this
article by Davey Alba in the business
section and the article is called want a
better web here's an idea
pay for it and it again outlined with
much more recent information because it
was from May 19th instead of April 17th
the latest in terms of how the YouTube
advertiser boycott is affecting the
David Pakman show
she also has a little quick summary the
history of the David Pakman show how we
started and it's a really really good
article go to wired.com want a better
web here's an idea pay for it and it it
basically got us up to speed with what
is going on currently with the YouTube
ad boycott which is we're down about
two-thirds of that revenue now we've
made up some of that revenue through
patreon and through membership that's a
really good thing we've still got a ways
to go and you know the saddest thing is
that we had major plans for 2017 in
terms of growth and expansion and
because of this a circumstance beyond
our control now we're in let's just get
back to where we were at the end of 2016
and some of the expansion plans
temporarily because I believe that
ultimately the audience will understand
the value and importance of programs
like ours and we will make up that
revenue temporarily the focus has become
let's get back to where we were and put
some of those growth plans on hold but
that's okay I genuinely you know if
there's nothing to sort of activate
against or in this case it's in favor of
more independent funding for our program
it can sort of become
uh you you can fall into into a sort of
non-moving inertia you know what I'm
trying to say
this has really activated so many people
in our audience and we have so many new
people the 1500 plus patreon donors and
over a thousand new members since the
this YouTube advertiser boycott started
so a lot of a lot of really good things
are going on and there's the possibility
in the back of my mind that we might
actually come out ahead right because if
we can replace that all of the missing
YouTube revenue now we're in the same
spot financially but way more
independent and then if the revenue
comes back in full or we continue to
grow we actually end up in a better and
more independent position okay so that's
the latest on the YouTube ad boycott
let's get back to super chat Frank
macwrite has sent a super chat saying
another issue the precedence Trump has
set I think you mean the precedent
precedent that Trump has set he got away
with so many awful things before the
election got elected anyway
got away with wiretapping claims etc do
you see a rise of similar candidates
running in the future I don't know about
similar to Trump but there's no doubt
that Donald Trump has normalized the
height of anti intellectual ignorant and
buffoonery as a sort of I hate to say
legitimate but it won him the election
as a sort of legitimate politic of sorts
and when I saw this poll that Dwayne the
rock Johnson was apparently leading
Trump in a hypothetical matchup for 2020
I was not at all surprised because now
that Trump has won I believe that there
has been an irreversible change to
American politics now will there be
similar candidates to Trump I don't know
I don't know but certainly candidates
that don't really know anything are have
been legitimized and there's a very
interesting video I recommend you watch
the video is about a year old it's only
four minutes long it's from the book of
life and it's about the vision of
democracy that Socrates had and the
argument that
made the argument that that Socrates
made back in well before 399 BC which is
when he was tried and ultimately
executed via the death penalty for
corrupting the youth as well as in piety
and I believe there was one other charge
against Socrates there is this idea of
democracy means everybody gets to vote
regardless of whether they're even
remotely informed Socrates had a
different version of democracy which is
democracy that actually has some minimum
knowledge that we want to ensure the
voting population has I'm not proposing
we instill this in the United States
what I am Telling You is that when you
have democracy in the way that we have
it what we are opening ourselves to is
people like Donald Trump who have no
business whatsoever running a country
and who are embarrassing our the country
every single day spilling secrets to
Russia telling Rodrigo Duterte the
palace the Filipino president where our
word to our nuclear submarines are etc
it's bad it's really really bad and I
encourage you to check out that video
it's very interesting gr sent a $5 Super
chat US Marine Corps etiquette training
used Trump's sexual assault assaults as
an example of conduct unbecoming until
his election DZ what's your take on
payouts so far I have no idea what
you're talking about payouts I don't
know what what that means what pay outs
were talking about and I did not know
that the United States Marine Corps
etiquette training was pointing to Trump
as behavior that is unbecoming if it's
true that is very very interesting okay
Jennifer karein has sent a $20 super
check Jennifer says I used to joke that
if Trump got elected he'd piss off a
country and we would get bombed I'm
starting to think I was right I can see
Donald Trump saying something that
angers a country and then retaliating
please tell me I'm off base I can't tell
you you're off base Jennifer because
next time Trump is on the phone maybe
it's not the Filipino president but it's
someone else and Donald Trump spills the
beans on the presence of
who knows what right the presence of a
nuclear sub here or there that a country
didn't know was there or whatever the
case may be that could absolutely lead
to an attack against the US or its
allies or US assets elsewhere I wish I
could tell you that you're you're crazy
and off-base Jennifer but you're kind of
not a Toni Merritt has sent a ten
British pound super Chad do you have any
plans to do an online discussion with
Kyle kolinsky over the Trump Russia
debate I don't know what the debate is
do you mean the Trump Russia scandal I
don't know that there's a debate as he
still seems to take a different point of
view to you on it
we've got nothing scheduled right now I
mean it depends on what if Kyle wants to
talk about stuff I'm glad to talk about
stuff with him that there's nothing
planned at the moment and I didn't think
that there was much of a trump rush of
debate I mean what we know is that
intelligence experts were concerned at
different points by interactions between
Trump and Russian Trump associates and
Russian officials and that it's being
investigated I don't know what the
debate is right I mean is we don't know
yet what it is that is going to come out
from those investigations so to me there
is really no debate Cameron Llewellyn
sent a to Australian dollar super chat
would love to see an apple bomb on the
David Pakman show about Trump I I know
the name but I don't remember exactly
who that is and Applebaum is an American
journalist Pulitzer prize-winning author
who has written about communism and the
development of civil society in Central
and Eastern Europe sounds interesting
she has a funny tweet after this is all
over I never ever want to hear again
about how businessmen would run the
government better than politicians yeah
fair point I will leave that up in
another tab and look into that that
seems like it would be very interesting
Kevin Elkin has sent a $5 super chat no
question or comment thanks very much
Kevin I appreciate that there is finally
a CBO score for the new version of the
American health
Care Act and it is really really really
bad the CBO has scored the updated
version of the American Health Care Act
which has been passed by the House by
the way stand still in the Senate
because it's Trump scandal day after day
after day the new version of the
American Health Care Act would likely
lead to 14 million more uninsured people
by 2020 and 23 million more uninsured
people within a decade meaning by 2017
it would also result in higher premiums
but anybody surprised I mean is is there
any surprise here whatsoever we knew
that this was part of the reason right
that Republicans in the House were so
quick to pass this thing before it could
be voted on most of them without even
reading the entire thing is because they
didn't want the CBO
to have time to score it because the
numbers were going to be a disaster and
it's obviously the case it was
everything that we knew and we didn't
know that much about what was actually
in the bill everything we knew about it
pointed in exactly this direction and
now we have the numbers 14 million by
2020 uninsured
additionally 23 million by 2017 is there
any political capital now for
Republicans in the Senate to pass this
they would have to pass something in
order to not have these numbers from the
CBO Republicans in the Senate would have
to change the bill so drastically that
it would not even remotely resemble what
Republicans passed in the house so it's
just completely unsurprising in every
way and we'll see now what what the
repercussions are politically when it
comes to the future of that bill and you
know that this gets me back to the
impeachment discussion that we were
talking about earlier we talked about
ways in which and at a formal
impeachment attempt against Donald Trump
could not be the best thing for
presses think about the last two weeks
right where it has been we've had
scandals the entire Trump presidency but
they've really accelerated in the last
couple of weeks who's talking about the
health care bill at this point I saw a
press conference with Paul Ryan Speaker
of the House where he tried to talk
about you know nitty-gritty wonky
political stuff nobody wants to hear
about it
right nobody wants to hear about it that
the the there's been no progress on a H
a since the Trump scandals have
accelerated the tax plan the tax plan
which we now know is completely
unaffordable because of a two trillion
dollar additional revenue stream for the
government that is counted twice in its
counted in the budget and it's counted
in the tax plan did a story on that
today who's talking about the tax plan
now I mean yeah Paul Ryan is trying to
take attention away from what's going on
with Trump but all of these proposals
are at a standstill now because of
what's going on with Donald Trump and
this is why I believe that the best
scenario politically for progressives
might be Trump stays in for the next
three plus years
it's scandal after scandal nothing gets
done and then Republicans implode in
2020 and hopefully also in 2018 in the
midterms although gerrymandering makes
that a little difficult I don't know I
mean that that actually might be the
best path forward Ellie sent a $10 super
chat I'm so proud of the work you guys
do
although politically controversial to
many in this country the show is
beneficial and will positively influence
our political system over time thank you
well thank you Ellie for the for the
kind kind words very very much
appreciate that
okay what's can somebody tell me what's
going on in the chat it's every once in
a while I'll take a look at it people
are calling for other people to be
banned I did block one guy who sent some
some crazy just insulted people but it
is is there it looks like we might not
have moderators today it might just
me do people need to get blocked is
there is there something going on that I
need to deal with if so let me know
somehow it is the chat moves very
quickly and it's tough to keep up but
I'm seeing escalation in the chat I
guess is what I mean
Viktor Savelle has sent a twenty dollar
super chat saying one last question I
have multiple strong Trump supporters in
my family and conversations get heated
at times how would you make a family
member think about their blind donald
trump support and open their eyes
besides a david pakman show link we have
been talking about this on the program a
little bit I believe Victor that there
is effectively no point in trying to
argue point counterpoint with your Trump
supporting family members and we've
talked about this with producer Pat
because he has Trump supporting family
members
i I don't really my family mostly
doesn't live in the US and they're all
liberal that I'm aware of and it's like
different shades of liberal that's more
common in Argentina where you've got a
stronger you've got a stronger further
left and then you've got the center left
and then you've got the middle there's
really no conservatives in my family I
think that you would be much better off
adopting a sort of Socratic method of
questioning to try to just ask questions
as to how your family members came to
the conclude that they have so if they
say I love what Trump's doing on the
wall you say really well what what has
he done that you like well he's building
the wall hmm has construction started
well I don't know no it hasn't started
it started oh okay
when do you think construction is going
to start oh it's going to start soon and
how long do you think it'll take always
going to get it done really where did
you where did you find out that it's
going to it's going to get done during
his first term oh well right just ask
questions and another really good
approach is what would change your mind
about that what what could Donald Trump
do that would make you not be happy with
his presidency so
I don't know they can't think of
anything that's a red flag right so
you're telling me that you're so
ideologically committed to this man that
it doesn't matter what he would do that
that doesn't sound like a thinking
person's perspective and if they if they
come up with some specific things then
you can maybe explore those I think that
that approach is way better way better
than trying to play point counterpoint
because you're not going to get anywhere
and actually studies show that the point
counterpoint stuff and the so-called
presentation of facts more often further
in grains people in their belief so I
don't think that that's the that's the
way to go that just some thoughts on
that all right let me send a couple more
thank yous out to people who have been
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership while we've been talking here
there is a coupon code available to you
that coupon code is I voted 17 why is
membership important membership is
important because that's the primary
source of funding for our show our
studio rent our connectivity being able
to afford staff salaries being able to
do all of the things that we do is
funded mostly by people who sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership or
make patreon pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show if you want to
use the 40% coupon code by all means use
it I have no problem with that
whatsoever if if you prefer to pay full
price by all means do that and skip the
coupon code so big thank yous going out
to Steven Potts
thank you to Victor Savelle thanks to
Yazeed a boon ayan thank you to Paul
Bentall all of whom have signed up in
addition to a whole bunch of other
people that I thanked earlier while
we've been talking here and you know the
there's no this is not a means-tested 40
percent discount if you can afford the
full price but just don't want to pay it
I'd rather you pay 60 percent then
nothing at all if you don't want to use
the coupon code by all means don't use
it
it's it's at this point it's just
important the more people we can have
financially engaged with what we're
doing the better the program will do
over time and in the wake of the YouTube
advertiser boycott that's really really
important I talked earlier about the
Wired magazine article by Davey Alba
that went live about five days ago about
our YouTube channel and what's going on
with the YouTube advertiser boycott
really really good article pointing that
out very very happy with that
earlier during the actually during April
the April vacation that we had a very
good article in The New York Times by
Amanda Hess about our YouTube channel
called how YouTube's shifting algorithms
hurt independent media well-researched
and just just really really great and
it'll explain to you why it is that I'm
talking about patreon patreon comm slash
David Pakman show it'll explain to you
why it is that I've been talking about
membership and uh you know we're doing
our thing it has this crisis has not
interrupted our program for the time
being my goal is that we don't change a
damn thing right that that would be my
desire in this entire thing let me
preview some of what's going to be on
tomorrow's program okay Republicans are
going to be crushing the poor to pay for
the tax cuts that they want to give the
rich
this is supply-side economics it doesn't
work and we're going to go after that on
the program tomorrow I wanted today to
talk about this we just didn't get to it
because there was so much else to
discuss Infowars has received White
House press credentials conspiracy
propaganda news website led by Alex
Jones Infowars is now part of the the
milieu there at the White House jerome
corsi an an absolute nut nut job wrong
word about James wrong a way to
characterize James Comey right way to
characterize jerome corsi
look him up okay jerome corsi is going
to be apparently the washington bureau
chief of Infowars i mean this is where
we are folks and he's going to be at the
White House and within hours of the
announcement of that Alex Jones was
criticizing the victims of the
Manchester bombing the ariana grande
concert bombing so we're going to talk
about that tomorrow we will talk about
this diplomatic facepalm as I'm calling
it caught on video in Israel when Donald
Trump arrived from Saudi Arabia to
Israel and said hey we just came from
the Middle East maybe he's never seen a
map I don't know we're also going to
talk about the Pentagon's concern over
Donald Trump mentioning to President
Rodrigo Duterte
that he has that the US has two nuclear
submarines in Korean waters and the
Pentagon did not like that we will talk
as I just mentioned about the new
Congressional Budget Office score for
the American Health Care Act
the republican-led health care proposal
14 million more uninsured people by 2020
23 million more uninsured people by 2027
and it's bad all right
also as a result of Trump's loose lips
in the Oval Office with Russian
officials Israel is going to they're
calling it an alteration to how they
share intelligence with the United
States they're not altering it in the
direction of sharing more with us right
that I can tell you for sure we're going
to talk about that tomorrow and then I
hope to get to this story if not we
might have to push it off until Friday
Fox News has fallen to third place in
the prime-time cable news ratings for
the first time in nearly seventeen years
a lot of this has to do with the fact
that Bill O'Reilly is out and now Rachel
Maddow's program is a top-rated program
a lot of it has to do with the fact that
Fox News has been pretending like
there's just nothing going on with Trump
that's that's at all concerning for the
last 3-4 months at this point for months
and people who exclusively watch Fox
News genuinely might not know that
there's a world of scandals out there
but anybody who's hearing from almost
any other news outlet knows that this
Rosie that this version through
rose-colored glasses that Fox News is
presenting is not info
firming them and that's a part of why
people are tuning out of [ __ ] - tuning
away from Fox News so I hope to get to
all of those stories and maybe more on
tomorrow's program we're also going to
talk to bill Scher who's been a longtime
frequent guest on the show he is going
to join us to talk about Democrats and
gun control and what is going on with
that there's actually a whole backstory
to that and I look forward to talking to
Bill about that tomorrow let's go back
to the super chat says e Canales has
sent a $20 super chat saying peace be
with you
thank you very much says he and Jacob
ball said with a $5 super chat Infowars
only got a day pass correct the same
kind they give high school kids I didn't
read about that let me see Infowars day
pass White House let's see what comes up
that would be interesting yeah Infowars
got a White House day pass just like a
real high school newspaper and there's
also a hill article pointing out that
they appeared to have gotten a just a
day pass and that they're lying about
the nature of the past that they
actually got so that's all very very
good news and I'm going to add it to my
research list here for tomorrow yeah
we're gonna we're going to talk about
all that thank you for pointing that out
Jacob very very relevant no doubt about
it
okay patreon.com slash david pakman show
david pakman.com slash membership a few
more thank yous okay Brian Stewart thank
you for signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership
Joleen Douglas thank you for signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
Beverly at rige Beverly at rigid
pavement comm slash membership the
coupon code has been and continues to be
available to you it is I voted 17 it
will save you 40% off of membership that
is the number one funding source for the
show thanks to everybody who joined me
today another live stream very very soon